salut et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
astuce du mercredi aujourd'hui je vais
vous apprendre à calculer deux têtes la
racine carrée d'un nombre ne fuyez pas
c'est très simple à faire là la seule
chose à avoir le seul prérequis à avoir
c'est de bien connaître tous ces carrés
de 1 à 9
aucun au carré 1,2 au carré deux trois
quarts et 3 jusqu'à 9 au carré 80
parfois ça arrive d'avoir des doutes sur
certains cars est comme mille fois en 8
ou 7 x 7 pour être sûr de bien avoir le
carré en tête pour pouvoir le vérifier
instantanément
je vous rappelle j'avais fait une astuce
était la vidéo numéro 27 je vous faire
une fiche ici comment extraire une
racine carré de tête c'est tellement
facile que je me demande pourquoi on
nous apprend passé à l'école quand vous
êtes prêts je prends le nombre 4225 et
donc notre but c'est d'extraire la
racine de 4225 ça se fait en deux étapes
la première c'est qu'on regarde l'unité
du nombre la c5 et on cherche quelques
arrêts parmi les chiffres de 1 à 9
fini par simple il n'y avait qu'un seul
c'est 5 5 x 5 25 c'est le seul donc je
sais que ma racine va finir par cinq là
je le note mais suffit juste de regarder
dans un coin de sa tête
ensuite la dizaine en oublie on s'en
occupera pas jamais que ce soit un
nombre à deux chiffres a trop chi x
kashif la dizaine de nous intéresse
jamais on s'intéresse donc à tout ce
qu'il ya avant la dizaine la centaine et
les milliers essayé qu'une certaine on
s'intéresse qu'à la centaine là c'est 42
on va chercher à l'encadrer quel est le
carré le plus proche en dessous et quel
est le carré le plus proche au dessus
le car est le plus proche en dessous ces
six parce que 6 x 6 36 et le plus proche
au dessus c'est cette puisque cette fois
7 49 et 40 de ces compris entre 36 et 49
celui du dessous c'est 36 et celui qui
avant 42 donc 36 pour la voir ses 6 x 6
donc je sais que ma racine va commencer
par 1,6 et c'est fini la racine de 4225
ses 65 c'est aussi simple que ça il ya
juste une petite chose à savoir en plus
vous la dirai juste après je refais un
exemple quand même facile tiens très
facile 144 unités qui finit par k2 parce
que 2 fois 2 4 la dizaine on occupe
jamais devant il nous reste 1 1 le 1
c'est entre le quart et de 1,1 et de
carrés de 2,4 mais le carré en dessous
c'est un fois celle là pour le coup ça
tombe pile poil
donc on sait que c'est un ça fait bien
12 racine carrée 244 c'est bien 12 12
soit 12 144 la petite chose à savoir
c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait quand il ya
deux unités dont il ya deux chiffres qui
permettent de retrouver cette unité par
exemple 4 au carré et six au carré
miss par la même unité ou que trois au
carré 7 au carré finissent par l'ama
unis laquelle choisir pour sans résultat
et bien c'est très simple c'est grâce à
l'encadrement que vous ai déjà appris
que vous allez pouvoir savoir ça quand
vous encadrer tout ce qui avant les
dizaines vous savez que vous allez
prendre le résultat qui est avant pour
écrire votre résultat donc à quoi sert
cet encadrement tout simplement à voir
de quel côté de l'encadrement pense le
plus la balance
c'est à dire s'il est plus proche de
celui qui est au dessus de lui
ça veut dire que dans votre choix vous
aurez à faire vous prendrez le plus
grand pour les unités c'est pas très
très clair a expliqué pourtant c'est
très facile à comprendre
exemple rapide avec 1156 si je regarde
le chiffre des unités c6 et il ya deux
carrés de chiffres qui finit par s'y
ciel car est de 16 4 x 4 16 et il ya 46
s'il faut 6 36 donc je les note là
maintenant j'oublie ma dizaine je
regarde ce cas avant et j'encadre ça
donc 11 c'est encadré entre 9 et 16
entre le quart et 2,3 et le 44 donc je
sais que mon résultat va commencer par
1,3 et du coup il finit par kw à 4 ou 6
et bien dans mon encadrement 11 c'est
plus proche de 9
ou c'est plus proche de 16 c'est plus
proche de 9 du plus petit donc je vais
prendre la plus petite des deux
possibilités c'est à dire 4 et le carré
de 34 c'est bien 1156 avec cette méthode
vous êtes capable maintenant d'extraire
n'importe quel racine carrée jusqu'à la
racine carrée de 10000 franchement ça te
fait c'est à dire que ça peut servir en
course il ya pas la calculatrice mais
aussi je trouve que quand même sac est
un peu en société de2 savoir extraire
une petite racine carrée à la fin du
repas tranquille je profite de cette
vidéo pour répondre aussi globalement
une question que vous me posez un petit
peu partout régulièrement ça revient
toujours
c'est où est-ce que j'ai eu ce bouclier
là où est ce qu'on peut trouver un
boulier chinois
donc ça c'est lui le boulier sinon
gouvernants dans toutes les vidéos donc
je vais vous mettre dans le descriptif
de cette vidéo et de la vidéo 51 qui
était la vidéo vous apprenez à vous
servir facilement d'un boulier le lien
où vous pouvez le trouver de mémoire
celui ci l'a un peu moins de 25 euros
mais au moins vous en verrez même
d'autres à d'autres prix si jamais vous
galérez en trouver un en tout cas penser
bien apprendre boulier chinois pour
avoir cette ligne la petite est celui du
jour je vais vous dire ce qu'on va faire
comme vidéo samedi ça me dit je vais
enfin vous parlez du col de reading ça
fait longtemps que vous me demandez je
voulais prendre le temps de préparer le
sujet chez encore si j'allais le faire
en une fois ou plusieurs fois il y aura
un masque
là sur le gold reding sur la lecture à
froid merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo n'oubliez pas de laisser le
petit pouce en l'air de ce mercredi le
petit point ce frère qui va bien le
fameux poussant la et n'oubliez pas
également de vous abonner à la chaîne si
ce n'est pas déjà fait et rendez vous
demain à 17 heures pour le prochain
mentale vlog ciao